o psol de 20 e hoje vou ensinar como
fazer minha espada ou então uma águia
então vocês podem parar em diamantino
punho é a coisa que eu mais gosto nesta
caminhada e é isso que 90 escolas que eu
faço não é nada dessas coisas
a primeira coisa que você tem que fazer
é dobrar a folha de modo a fazer um
triângulo imposto terá parte fico de
fora quando abriu triângulo ter um
quadrado
depois dobre para fazer mais uma
diagonal dobre ao maio para um lado e
para o outro lado podem parar ficar sem
ajuda o outro a junta a outra prática
que eu vou fazer é a briga
é como eu não vou usar este grande usar
um bem mais pequenino e já não lembro
das dimensões desde pequenino mas a 10
por 10 tem de fazer uma rifa
caso não consigam fazer não consiga
fazer aprender no final tem que fazer
contra fifa só que esta é diferente é
uma rifa o campo dentro
esse é o prudente você consegue espalmar
e depois vou usar aquilo que digo vocês
vão ver como vai largar o corinthians
bom é só aprender com fita e já está
a última folha fazer a lâmina vou dobrar
ou mãe foi dobrar para a linha de banho
de um lado e do outro em ficar semetre
dobra através da linha do mai tem agora
uma parte à outra
eu vou usar fita se vocês quiserem podem
usar cola também é igual aquela curva
normal fora depois encaixar no fla para
dentro com ela e vou aprender onde acaba
a lâmina
rodando algumas voltas
brendan hansen maico uma proteção para a
mão em cima da lâmina menina vocês fazem
para tirar aquela parte o vertis
encaixar lá
por cola já está aqui nos comentários
mas fontes da manhã
é isso o trânsito está a completar
sequer se vai ter a bandeira e é isto
que tal e espanha